georges des maths bonjour bonjour matrix
est le fondateur avec christine coudun
de la compagnie black blanc beur vous
êtes un acteur important de la scène
culturelle notamment dans ce territoire
et vous est le coauteur avec frédéric
d'une tribune sur la crise de la
démocratie culturelle en effet oui enfin
avec frédéric année puis d'autres
nombreux membres de l'association art
factories autres parents c'est important
de disons que c'est factories c'est un
groupement de porteurs de projets dont
la particularité est de s'impliquer dans
les rapports art territoire population
nous sommes aujourd'hui environ 70
membres français et 300 membres
internationaux c'est à la fois un centre
de ressources et un lieu de réflexion et
des changes alors vous dites en gros
c'est ça la démocratie culturelle est en
crise comment vous là comment elle se
manifeste cette crise alors
d'abord c'est une crise sémantique dire
que c'est celui qui remplit le premier
lesmo qui finalement est gardien d'un
sens
je m'explique tout le monde veut
poursuivre la démocratisation culturelle
mais la démocratisation culturelle ça
implique que l'art n'est pas
démocratique
voudrais vous dites d'ailleurs voilà
voilà l'ars ellard ddd grèce dominant
tout faux le grand art c'est là mais
elle revient sur tout et jusqu'à la
moitié jusqu'à la fin du xxème siècle
c'étaient les élites bourgeoises qui une
fois enrichi voulait se raffiner se
cultiver et je pense que tu es bon aloi
jusqu'à fixer les élites dans nos pays
est sous nos contrées la particularité
de ces dernières années c'est que
l'élite n'est plus une élite raffinée et
cultivée c'est une élite d'argent j'ai
rien changé à changer les choses ah bah
oui oui parce que aujourd'hui ce qui
fait
haute qualité ce qui fait sens oui ou
alors ce qui fait eau de qualité et
qu'il ne fait pas le même sens et c'est
la massification d'un certain nombre de
projets artistiques disons populaire au
sens oui touche le plus grand nombre
avec un danger immédiat c'est le fait
qu'il ya un hyper développement grâce à
l'industrie d'un certain nombre de
formes et que toutes les formes
minoritaires celles qui permettent
justement l'expression d'une diversité
en pâtissent et ça fait au moins cinq
ans que c'est le cas car est ce que vous
dites amant est d'ailleurs parfois
culture populaire ou sa culture pauvres
voilà c'est la culture de virer des on
nous l'a dit à nous mais on nous a dit
au ministère de la culture les premières
années de black blanc beur que c'était
de la série b
ça voulait pas alors ils seront n'est
même pas compte que de nous le dire
c'était une manière de se placer au
dessus c'était une manière de même de
qualifier la série b de merde alors que
de la merde il y en a dans toutes les
séries d'après n'a pas toutes les séries
malheureusement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que puisque voilà vous
dites y ait une autre élite au fond qui
a pris le pouvoir qu'ils aient pas les
mêmes valeurs qui allègue qui fait pas
sens avec les mêmes choses
qu'on tire des choses vers le bas
non l'idée c'est surtout qu'on puisse
permettre à toutes les catégories de
population de construire eux-mêmes leur
rapport à l'art parce que la deuxième
idée dans le papier
qui est développé dans ce papier avec
frédéric cannes c'est l'idée qu'a un
moment
comment dirais-je les
ça n'est pas en contact à l'oeuvre si
génial soit elle qui d'un seul coup et
claire les gens c'est le fait de
pratiquer soi même de développer
soi-même ses propres perceptions qui
permet aux gens de se raffiner de
d'obtenir et de construire plus de
références au monde extérieur et pas
seulement rapports extérieurs l'oeuvre
quoi enfin exactement c'est
véritablement une construction un
personnel et ce qui me paraît pas
nouveau mais il est encore extrêmement
important de dire c'est que dans le fond
c'est plus
faire de l'art que les gens veulent que
de consommer de là où être les témoins
mondain d'un grand raffinement dollars
c'est ce que vous avez vous essayez
toujours de faire c'est ce que nous
avons tenté de faire avec tous les gens
comme comme comme nous les gens des
visages belle de mai elle est d'ailleurs
en fait on pourrait le résumer en
quelque chose d'assez asseko en même
temps qui est long à développer ensuite
c'est depuis le début on essaie de
construire un nous est ce nous j'en
parlais tout à l'heure presque en
rigolant mais je viens de lire le
dernier goncourt oui la révère français
de la guerre ben oui mais tout est là
dedans c'est à dire que on trimballe les
mêmes problèmes que ceux qu'on a eu
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre de 45 à
savoir on a remis dans les rues peel et
plus les plus pourris notre mémoire un
certain nombre de positions dominantes
de blocage de l'histoire qui font qu
abandonner ce nous qui était un nou où
tout le monde saigne à égalité enfin
il y en a qui des mauvaises langues
disaient qu'ils mettaient les noirs et
les arabes de vendre dans les
cornouailles est à égalité dans un coup
le 8 mai 45 ans ça devient un entre nous
c'est nous qui avons gagné et nous cas
pas gagné nicholas de catalan dans ce
bouquin c'est fabuleux parce qu'on voit
à travers l' aventure le regard qui est
porté sur ce héros de la deuxième guerre
extérieure qui fait ensuite et c'est que
c'est sale guerre mais pour revenir à ce
que ce coup d'une mesure la culture est
ce que vous pensez que voilà ce que ça
cette crise elle vient d'une volonté ou
d'une absence de volonté politique ou à
ce qu'elle vient au fond d'une évolution
de la société qui est aussi là qui fait
que les jo il trouve peut-être leur
bonheur ailleurs il ya internet il ya il
ya plein de sollicitations qu'il faut
que c'est plus difficile peut-être de
les attirer aussi vers les spectacles
culturels je pense que quand les deux
mais je vous expliquais en moins les
deux d'abord parce que dès la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
difficultés à construire se noue
persistance d'une douleur pour certains
peuples je pense aux pieds noirs qui eux
se sont retrouvés gommer de l'histoire
complètement et c'est pas parce que je
pas d'origine pied noir lui même
d'origine algérienne et socialement mais
vos parents décident en france oui
absolument mais en plus il n'était pas
particulièrement a requis non plus n'y
fait que c'est encore des positions
comme un peuple subtil et plus complexe
moi ce que je vois c'est qu'à un moment
donné ça se résume bien dans le dans
dans le livre de comment s'appelle jenny
je crois le riche génie jg ni ses
ennemis tous bloc à la sortie de 39 de
la guerre de 39 40 quand un moment donné
il est dit on aura la paix pour dix ans
sous cette phrase il y a une manière de
plus vouloir aller plus loin toujours la
construction se noue une manière de
remettre en cause cette capacité à vivre
ensemble et depuis ce moment là cette
guerre qui était une voie qui n'était
pas d'ailleurs
c'était de la pacification s'était pas
donné comme une guerre je parle en chine
comme lg si vous n'appelez pas sa guerre
absolument on a développé une certaine
type de méthodes d'investigation des
populations mais aujourd'hui c'est celle
que je vois dans nos banlieues à ce
moment là ah oui je pense c'est son
esprit c'est sa manière c'est l'epr est
derrière lesquelles l'état français les
français sont retranchés depuis cette
période c'est cette sorte de deux virus
comme ça qui s'est développée oui bien
sûr fondée sur la peur de l'autre sur la
peur de la différence
c'était pas vraiment des guerres et on
les a pas vraiment gagner non d'accord
pour le moment la subtilité que je avoir
ce que j'essaie de faire passer là et
j'ai l'impression que
toute cette mémoire elle est en repli
dans la pensée militaire consiste à
celles qui sont dans la pensée policière
français c'est celle qui est toujours à
l'oeuvre aujourd'hui mais pourtant alors
sur le fond j'entends bien aller méthode
bon
faire des progrès pour l'électricien non
mais c'est plus morale que physique à ce
qu'est ce que vous racontez mais vous
même rappelé au début vous êtes le
fondateur de la compagnie black blanc
beur il ya eu avec la création notamment
des villes nouvelles une sorte d'utopie
formidable sur la culture dans les
années 80
qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue elle est
en crise celle là aussi aujourd'hui
c'était il ya eu des moments
particuliers il ya des moments
particuliers où il est vraiment
nécessaire que les artistes les gens qui
sont capables de mettre en oeuvre un
imaginaire collectif
fasse peur leur travail pour que une
vérité une ville légitime une vraie
ville apparaissent cette période elle a
fait renaître voilà cette période là
elle a effectivement elle est révolue
alors est ce qu'elle est en crise je
pense que c'est l'idée d'une forme enfin
de penser de l'éducation populaire qui à
mon avis a été d'abord en crise dans la
pensée de gauche et la gauche qui a pas
cru elle même qui fait qu'à un moment
donné on se retrouve sur un modèle qui
permet à tout point de vue qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la mondialisation au sens
large mais qui prend sur le dans le
domaine culturel une allure particulière
c'est celle abandonnée de d'un primat de
l'offre et de la demande d'un prix mal
de ce qui plaît au public qui est d'un
primat de ceux qui se consomme vite et
qui rapportent beaucoup voile alors là
on parle et vous parler enfin sur les
principes et de façon générale mais ça
forcément des conséquences sur des
compagnies comme les autres voilà le
financement les spectateurs se sent ça
devient compliqué aujourd'hui c'est
difficile parce que ce que nous
espérions est ce que nous espérons
toujours que la gauche mette en oeuvre à
savoir de dynamiser un espace
intermédiaire qui soit à la fois
composer des outils de l'économie privée
associative et d août des outils de
l'économie publique c'est à dire
l'économie redistributive et celle qui
est le rôle de l'état qui à mon avis
doit être minimal mais quand même
extrêmement important pour définir ce
qui fait qualité et bien ce système là
n'a pas été développée n'a pas été promu
est aujourd'hui soit on est sous la
férule d'un système public et
hiérarchisé
donc si on n'a pas choisi comme c'est le
cas pour christine de prendre la
direction d'un centre chorégraphique des
halles il ya il ya aussi des coteries
point de salut à voir voilà c'est le
bing absolument mais tout ça est quand
même dans une verticalité affligeante
une verticale by danlos divisional
public affligeant alors ça c'est une des
hypothèses l'autre hypothèse c'est le to
lie béral le tout sur le marché et je
pense qu'un des bons exemples de ce qui
fonctionne mais qui est tout seul
aujourd'hui donc ça doit interroger
c'est le festival de suresnes le
festival de suresnes il a véritablement
mis en place une sorte d'économie de
visibilité de ce lieu le problème c'est
qu'ils sont à la fois producteurs
diffuseurs et quand on est bien informé
on se rend compte qu'ils ont aussi un
rapport à q1 organiser les moyens
publics quand même assez privilégiés du
coup il ya quand même là quelque chose
qui cloche est-ce qu'on donne pas voilà
des moyens ce qu'on se donne pas bonne
conscience of horror en privilégiant
quelques festivals comme ça aux quelques
mythes lecture peut-être mais je pense
que c'est aussi des lieux qui dont
l'idéologie ou l'absence d'idéologie je
dirais même pour être plus sincère
encore
rassure vous devez dire est que vous
faites peur peut-être un je crois oui je
crois qu on a fait peur on fait plus
peur de la même manière mais dans ce
pays et en europe d'une manière générale
vouloir construire un nous là où toute
la pensée artistique et construire
autour du jeu l'un des triomphants
c'est quand même encore un super
problème merci beaucoup changé bataille
sera pas le cas il ya deux spectacles
qui qui qui viennent d'émerger les
premiers actuels gré de mes de presse
c'est donc maï maï tati freeze et et
puis en supersonique du périmètre qu'on
verra notamment le 2 juin de juin bercy
ou en rire mais on va on va donner tout
est là merci infiniment récit merci
également